all right welcome back i'm here with
chef jet tila and we're cooking up a
classic
pad thai
now uh jet you just threw in some bean
sprouts and some scallions a little
peanut absolutely we want to finish with
a little bit of crunch so here's how we
serve this dish in thailand i haven't
seen it here so i wanted to do it here
in your show it's called like an egg
crepe or like an egg parcel so in your
pan to the side we're going to just put
enough oil to kind of coat the bottom it
doesn't have to be a lot and then just
enough egg
to when i coat when i kind of swirl we
coat the bottom we're basically just
making like an egg pancake but there's
no flour in here just egg and then as
that's setting up drew we're going to
take our pad tie
we're going to throw it and if yours
isn't set up yet we've made these ahead
of time the magic of the magic of
television so you do it that way so we
can show our friends at home
i'm going to do it in the kitchen style
like in the pan style oh my god it's
like actually setting perfectly isn't
that cool yeah i don't think we need to
i think i think it's looking pretty good
uh and then watch i'm gonna i'm gonna
just wrap the egg and i'm gonna grab a
plate do i have a plate i'm gonna use
this plate right here and then what we
do is we're going to take it i'm going
to fold over the sides and this is how
we do in thailand we're going to fold
make a little parcel all right oh i'm
really watching no no wish me luck
because because i went a little
ambitious let's see if i can do this
all right here we go
oh
we did it perfect we totally did it
and then what we'll do is i'm gonna it's
like a little present that you make for
someone you care about so a little bit
of pad ties there now i want to do it
now you're gonna do it you're gonna do
it totally hey i have dainty wrists to
begin with there it is
yeah all right where's that let's give
you a plate let's get a plate
all right i got your back okay i got you
all right are we doing you wanna do this
together yes okay you invert with me
three two
yeah yeah let go
you totally did it look
we did it oh my god wait that looks
awesome
mine doesn't that's jack i told you
you're in good hands i got your back
drew oh my god i've never done anything
like that
you're all garnished um pad thai anytime
just like that
here we go
stick that over there
do we get to do the best part now oh yes
try it i need to oh my god i'm so
excited this is truly my favorite dish
you nailed the pad thai oh my god thank
you so much oh it looks piping hot too
yes
yes
thank you for teaching me the way of one
of my very favorite dishes and for all
the generations of your family who
continue to bring your culinary
expertise to the world thank you so much
thank you for hanging out thanks for
letting me teach you pad time yeah get
out there eat more thai food check it
out oh my god typhoon is my very
favorite thank you jet tila jet book 101
dishes that you need to cook before you
die
is available now wherever books are sold
and that my friend is a great way to
live
is to eat these recipes and cook from
this book
[Music]